pour un producteur maraîcher il n'ya
probablement rien d'aussi crève coeur
que d'amener une culture à maturité des
fruits des légumes et de voir les
laisser pourrir au chant faute de bras
pour les cueillir la crise de lakovic 19
a révélé plus que jamais l'immense
dépendance du secteur agricole à la main
d'oeuvre étrangère
on savait qu'il y avait une pénurie de
travailleurs mais on a compris à quel
point le problème était criant
[Musique]
quand les choux gras des passes les
plants de légumes c'est signe qu'il y a
un problème dans les champs on est de
faire les coins ronds on n'a pas pu
faire de sarclage comme une deuxième
fois il y a pire que les mauvaises
herbes
l'été des producteurs maraîchers a été
un stress du début à la fin
évidemment on ne la co ville on à la
sécheresse puis la médaille dans
lanaudière
les douze employés guatémaltèque de
michel ricard de saint-elix s'ils ne
sont pas arrivées privé d'employés
réguliers
il fonctionne avec une agence de
placement de montréal bon normalement
des fois qu'on dise ce matin hier ils
étaient trop c'est comme ça tous les
jours
demain aux et on recommence et parfums
et la journée devant lui avant de passer
à damas
les pertes sont évidentes des tonnes de
concombres bon à manger
délaissée faute de main d'oeuvre fiable
et spécialisés
on peut dire que le gros de la récolte
des kasmas porcine dans le canton
puis je répète mais des étrangers qui
est rendue essentielle je le vois cette
année deux événements a dit l'essentiel
parce que la mairie mais des blocages
c'est vraiment son champ de concombres
couvre 10 ha oui sylvain potasse est
d'ailleurs annoncée 250 tonnes de cacao
présente mal arrive on est on est obèse
ramos et 150 tonnes une partie qu'on a
pu donner à moisson lanaudière mais
aussi pour des grosses quantités père
ressources que c'est qu'on est capable
produits mais sinon ça va rester au
chaud les concombres de michel ricard
sont vendus à petit calibre pour en
faire que des cornichons le problème
c'est que le passage de la catégorie
cornichons à confondre est fulgurant et
pourtant le seul gros soldats issus
place et seulement deux à trois jours du
départ à la chaleur qu'on a mais cet été
que la chaleur qu'on avait c'était pas
long
normalement les hôtels les restaurants
et les cafétérias sont preneurs pour les
concombres plus gros ils en font des
tranches ou de la religion mais dans ces
secteurs
tout tourne au ralenti y a pas de
demande pour ce type de contrats
importants la qualité est bonne mais le
marché a comme tomber à cause la coved
cette année sont % de la récolte du
concombre se fait à la main au québec à
l'été 2000 20 700 tonnes soit plus du
dixième du volume total a été perdu le 5
juin au québec
à peine le tiers des travailleurs
étrangers nécessaires étaient arrivés
fin où il en manquait toujours 25 % en
ontario pour la même période en nous
trente pour cent des travailleurs
étrangers n'avaient pas reçu un permis
de travail en colombie britannique
c'était presque 40 % dans l'ensemble du
canada
il manquait 30 % des travailleurs
étrangers dans les fermes
au total sur cinquante-huit mille
employés attendu seulement un peu plus
de 40000 se sont présentés ou pis là
qu'ovide plus ce qui est arrivé le coc
vidal pays des travailleurs qui a eu des
problèmes de fermeture de bureaux elle a
eu vraiment des gens qui ont dû reporter
le travail
donc ça bouchonne et puis on a été pris
à entendre ces gens là le normalement on
a deux dates d'arrivée
cette année sur le groupe on a eu cette
date d'arrivée puis on lit à sol et 40 m
les allemands allaient faire l'épicerie
pour ces gens là ça nous a demandé de la
gymnastique
les mesures sanitaires mises en place
dans les fermes au québec n'ont pas
empêcher l'infection à l'aco vide d'au
moins une quarantaine de travailleurs
étrangers
la situation était plus dramatique en
ontario des éclosions dans des fermes du
sud ouest de la province ont entraîné la
mort de trois employés et quelques
centaines de travailleurs contaminé des
mesures sanitaires inadéquates en
ontario en début de saison et la
contamination par des employés locaux
seraient en cause ce qui est un homme ça
vous tenterait de venir travailler avec
nous agriculteurs dans nos champs
l'appel de québec lancé à la population
pour venir travailler aux champs a été
un échec même si l'offre était
accompagnée de différentes primes
salariales de québec et d'ottawa
la province avait un objectif de 8500
travailleurs locaux
le 9 septembre à peine 1824 personnes
avaient travaillé au moins une journée
dans les fermes depuis le début de la
saison
c'est peu en répondu présent il y a eu
quelques expériences heureuses salle
avec comme ce groupe de jeunes femmes
venues secourir une productrice d'aspect
rj à l'île d'orléans
ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu une
équipe aussi joyeuse un peu fofolle donc
eu du beau qui ressort de toute cette
histoire de la majorité des personnes
qui ont tenté l'expérience n'ont pas
persévéré la rétention est un grave
problème pour michel ricard aussi je
dois de rendre à 150 personnes de poser
cette année en tant que non je vous
demanderais bien en temps normal j'en
avais besoin de 16 à 20 personnes
tous les matins il doit enseigner le
métier à de nouvelles personnes il y en
a qui sont vraiment efficaces un montant
pourrait avoir d'autres
ils viennent troubler le travail qu il
visait faut pas se cacher il ya du monde
qui sa peau c'est quoi non plus le
travail d'un champ ils viennent en
pensant ça se fait facilement
mais si mes jeunes mais après une
journée c'est trop
la chaleur tout fait en sorte qu'ils
reviennent pas le producteur est au bout
du rouleau gaulle et légumes de
transformation comme les haricots ou les
pois verts la récolte est largement
mécanisée mais dans plusieurs cultures
il n'y a pas encore de récolteuse
disponibles comme les fraises les
salades le maïs sucré ou les pommes
malheureusement c'est à regret que je
dis que auparavant on travaille avec des
gens locaux puis les larges en
condamnant salaires restaient locale
mais maintenant si on veut faire ça on
va arrêter produits mais pourtant dans
bien des cas ça aurait pu être une bonne
récolte comme ici lutte hectares de
plants de piment banane prêt dans
quelques semaines mais la récolte est
incertaine
alors que la population n'a jamais
autant souhaiter même exigé les produits
locaux
les producteurs se sent impuissant à lui
fournir la nourriture
si on veut avoir quelque chose dans nos
assiettes de deux lits locale mais ça
prend d'année de l'étranger ce nom le
monde si on est au chaud qui manquent de
mon nous il y en a il y ait plus de
monde sont intéressants détaillée d'un
champ ça va être la fin michel ricard
devait recevoir douze travailleurs du
guatemala début juillet
finalement il en est arrivé 4 à la fin
du mois d'août et au terme de leur
quarantaine
la saison des cornichons sera
malheureusement terminée
la coved a ravivé le souci de
l'autonomie alimentaire à la semaine
verte on prépare d'ailleurs une émission
spéciale sur cette question qui sera
diffusé le 17 octobre